es una carrera contrareloj encasillar
los equipos de emergencia esperan
rescatar a las personas que siguen
atrapadas bajo lo que queda de sus
propias casas en medio de la noche un
misil ruso destruyó totalmente este
edificio residencial de cinco pisos y
dañó una gran parte del inmueble vecino
estaba en la habitación y cuando salí
todo empezó a tronar ya crujir no podría
explicarlo con palabras me salvé cuando
entré corriendo en un momento dado todo
se derrumbó
por supuesto
entre los escombros algunos residentes
tratan de hacer un balance de sus
posesiones como bots
factura mi esposo y yo no estamos
heridos pero todo ha sido arrojado todo
está dañado todas las ventanas todo está
roto ciclo pongas tropa humana el
presidente de la scj y denunció un
ataque deliberado contra civiles ya
ciliar se encuentra al sureste de cra
motors que ciudad que también ha sido
atacada recientemente
se espera que se convierta en un
objetivo importante para las fuerzas
rusas en su intento de obtener el
control total del este de ucrania